just before we get started i do want to
say that this video is brought to you by
beardblaze
some of you may have heard this before
but i've got another channel called
business plays and that actually led to
the development
of this very product right here long
story short i made a joke about how
youtubers have beauty products and
a fan of the channel email me saying
simon don't make a beauty product bake a
beer doll we'll make it together
and we did and we made it excellent
beard blaze makes a full
luscious beard a reality solving all of
life's problems with fine facial hair
not a guarantee
life's problems that is this will make
your beard awesome
the guy i made this with will he sent me
a bunch of samples from his lab and i
rubbed them into my beard chose the best
ones and then we came up with the line
of beer dolls which are all available
at beardblaze.com so head over there
check them out pick some up if you are a
bearded fellow
and let's get into today's video oh also
we made them in big bottles for
reasonable prices i should just say that
as well because i've bought really i've
bought build holes before
they always come really small and really
expensive this is large
you're welcome
he's one of the most prolific writers in
human history in the mid 19th century
alexandre dumas
thrilled audiences with his tales of
historical romance and daring do
they thought to have published 37
million words in his lifetime
he turned out plays think pieces and
travelogues faster than most of us can
compose a shopping list
but it was in the realm of novels that
dumas really made his mark the genius
behind popular classics like the three
musketeers the counter monte cristo and
the man in the iron mask dumas remains
one of the few french authors
you could call a household name yet
despite his towering reputation today
the road to greatness for tomorrow was
marked by near-insurmountable obstacles
born to a poor interracial couple at a
time when being rich and white was very
much
in dumar struggled at first to even make
his voice heard yes it would be this
very voice
breathless frantic compelling you to
keep on reading
that would make him one of the most
popular authors ever today biographics
is
hoisting its rapier donning its cavalier
hat
and diving into a world of romance and
[Music]
adventure
on the night of february the 25th 1806
young alexander dumas
sat awake in his uncle's house listening
to the storm raging outside
somewhere on the other side of their
small town of villier cottere
the boy's mother was keeping vigil by
his father's bedside
helpless to do anything but watch the
cancer sap his life
around midnight the wind began to blow
stronger a knocking sound came from the
door
it was young dimar decided his dad's
spirit
coming to say goodbye today it's unknown
if this anecdote recorded in dumas
autobiography actually happened real or
fictitious though it's a perfect
metaphor
for the rest of his life alexander dumas
would be haunted by the ghost of the
father
that he barely knew born on july 24 1802
dumar came from a background society had
trouble classifying while his mother
marie was an innkeeper's daughter his
father
thomas alexandra or simply alex was an
aristocrat who'd
abandoned his life of luxury to fight in
france's revolutionary wars
a tale you can check out in our
swashbuckling video on him by the way
although he'd risen to general and
fought alongside napoleon alex had
ultimately been betrayed and
left rot in a dungeon eventually
returning to civilian life a broken man
but perhaps the most significant thing
about marie and
alex's marriage wasn't the class
difference but
the racial one alex's mother dumas
grandmother
had been a black slave in the former
french colony of saint-domingue now
haiti when alex married marie it had
been at a time of increased racial
equality in france
but then the revolutionary era had ended
and a backlash began against france's
non-whites by the time dumar was born
things had gotten so bad that his mother
is said to have cried for joy
when she saw his light skin and his blue
eyes
her son could pass for white maybe that
alone would be enough to save him
from the cruelty her husband had
suffered not that youngjimar was the
sort of boy who needed saving
the day after his father's death in 1806
murray caught the boy marching upstairs
one of alex's old pistols in hand when
she asked what he was doing
he replied he was going to heaven to
kill god who killed daddy
it was the sort of reply that would have
surely made the dead general alex smile
the death of alex left the already poor
family teetering on the edge of poverty
a situation not helped by napoleon's
refusal to pay his former general's
pension
yet while this was doubtless stressful
for marie young dumar
barely seems to have noticed unable to
afford a standard education demar spent
his childhood wandering the woods
learning to
hunt learning to fence and listening to
the stories his
mother told of alex's wartime exploits
stories that would resurface many years
later
in his greatest fiction but the moment
that perhaps had the biggest impact on
dumas life was
seeing a single carriage go by it was
a disastrous year for french forces and
the carriage
was returning from the war inside was
napoleon who'd come by in the opposite
direction not long before looking
regal and grand now though he looked not
like a serene emperor
but a beat down defeated man crushed
and humiliated as young dumar ran
alongside the carriage he had no way of
knowing that
he was witnessing the twilight of the
napoleonic era
when the sun next rose it would be on to
a new france one with
new tastes with a craving for escapist
fiction
and alexander dumas would soon be
perfectly positioned
to give the public exactly what they
wanted
[Music]
in the spring of 1814 alexander dumas
faced a tricky choice
napoleon had abdicated and waterloo and
100 days aside the bourbon monarchy had
been restored
under louis xvi since general alex had
come from a noble family dumar
might be able to escape his life of
poverty by reclaiming his dad's title
and joining the aristocracy to do so
though would go against everything that
his republican father had believed in
in the end that was just a step too far
for dumar
rather than try and ingratiate himself
into the royalist system
dumas settled for being an assistant
clerk in vilier cottere
and a life of playing billiards and
chasing girls there he could have
probably stayed
had it not been for one man adolf de
leuven was a guy
who loved theater almost as much as he
loved to party he met dumar while
visiting villier cottere and
discovered a kindred spirit a gregarious
man who
enjoyed his food and booze shortly after
meeting dulun took dumat to paris to see
a play what the young man saw
in the theater blew his mind for dumas
plays were as big of a revelation
as sex or discovering how good it feels
to eat an entire carton of ben and
jerry's while
wearing only your underpants he decided
then and there that he was going to move
to paris and become a famous playwright
he certainly succeeded at the first part
in spring of 1823 dumas managed to win
90 francs hustling billiards
enough to get to the capitol and give
him time to find his feet then clutching
a stack of introductory letters from
marie to his father's old war buddies
he waved goodbye to villier cottere for
good like many young people heading off
to make their fortunes dumar probably
assumed that he was going to arrive in
paris be embraced by the city
and instantly become a household name
like most other young people dumar
quickly discovered that the real world
doesn't actually work like that his
father's friends
barely wanted to acknowledge him he had
to take a tiny room to survive
his one break came when his dad's former
comrade general foy
noticed his beautiful handwriting and
got him a clerking job with the duke de
olion the cousin of king louis xvi
but the duke didn't pay well and the
other clerks rarely missed an
opportunity to make racially charged
comments about dumas
mocking his kinky hair and his non-white
features
still a job was a job and dumar was able
to save enough to finally self-publish
his first book nouvelle contemporane
it's sold four copies yep not 40 not 400
or even 14.
four four measly copies at least one of
which was probably bought by a guy just
looking for something classy to
wipe his bum whiz it was the sort of
humiliating knock that many young
writers don't recover from for a while
it looked like dumab wouldn't either
putting literature aside he instead
began to study trying to make up for the
huge gaps in his education
he met a woman catherine le bay and
moved in with her they had a son
also named alexander dumar who would
become a writer
today the french know ardumar as pear
and the sun
as fee to tell them apart as the 1820s
dragged on it began to look like future
youtube biographers would
have to title their videos alexander
dumas obscured dude that no one's ever
heard of but
we'd actually just never make that video
at all but of course things were about
to change
as 1827 dawn dumas was on the verge of a
breakthrough
that would turn him from four book loser
into one of french literature's greatest
stars
[Music]
in the end it wasn't life in paris that
gave dumar the inspiration he so badly
needed but events that had happened
nearly 200 years earlier
in the 17th century queen christina of
sweden had become
involved in a lurid plot of
assassination the details were vague but
when dumar read about it it caused an
old-timey light bulb to
ping on above his head rather than
building up a plot from scratch why
didn't he just take this historical
episode
spice it up dial up the emotion and
create a melodramatic masterpiece
the process of writing christine was
what's technically known as
a gigantic pain in the butt dumab was
working long hours for the duke to only
own and
at home he had a screaming baby that he
needed to take care of
once he got so angry at the wailing
child that he picked his son out of the
crib and
hurled him onto the bed in his own
autobiography demar junior would later
claim
i can still see myself in the air
annoying as
it was though writing christine soon
began to pay off in 1828 dumas play was
accepted for production
on the back of that demar was able to
snag an invite to morsi nodies
salon where paris's literary types all
hung out
there he met and seduced the
well-connected melanie
waldorf using her contacts to get him
further into the intellectual society at
the same time christine being accepted
had given him a newfound confidence
dimar dashed off another historical play
ori iii which
was likewise accepted and moved into
production ahead of christine he began
to meet people like victor hugo and
arnold
balzac up and comers in the new styles
of french writing
unfortunately there were others who
noticed tomorrow's rise too in late 1828
the dukedom lior head of office summoned
the young playwright
look here the professional stuffed shirt
basically said it's not right for the
king's cousin to have an
artist on his staff either you drop this
theater nonsense
or i'll fire you dimar took the latter
option
ori iii debuted on february 11 1829 the
first dumas play to ever see production
the house
was packed that night dumar himself was
so nervous that he forgot to wear a
collar
so in a panic he quickly made one out of
cardboard but
he didn't have worried while demar's
plays are too bombastic for modern
tastes they were exactly what 1820s
france was craving
the audience acted like this was opening
night for
avengers end game they were swept away
by the grand emotions and
glittering production design among their
number was the duke to only all
although his head of office might not
have liked the idea of an artist in the
duke's staff
the duke himself loved it seeing how
henry iii had gone down he immediately
rehired dumas this time with a much
bigger salary
for a beginner writer to get such a
powerful patron was a rare stroke of
luck
and the duke was about to get even more
powerful on july
26 1830 the then king charles the tents
published a document
known as the four ordinances effectively
outlawing the last remaining democratic
rights won in the french revolution
this being france the unwashed masses
were all like
somebody say revolution the three
glorious days saw barricades on the
streets of paris gunfights and
the king fleeing into exile before
somebody decided to remove his head
dumora himself
fought on the streets but it would be
what was happening behind the scenes
that would have the biggest
impact on him on july the 30th 1830 a
cabal of wealthy liberals conspired to
use the chaos to place the duke to olion
on the throne
crowning him king louis philippe the
first it was the dawn of the july
monarchy a new liberal order in france
that would last for 18 years
it would also be a period in which
alexander dumas rose
to the very top
[Music]
although dumar had fought in the
revolution that turned the duke only
into king louis philippe the first he
hadn't gone out on the streets for his
patron's sake
all his life the playwright had felt the
shadow of his father hanging over
everything he did
in private he told friends he felt he
needed to replicate his dad's
revolutionary career
all of which may explain what happened
next after keeping quiet all through the
reigns of
louis xvi and charles the tenth dumas
suddenly became very vocal about
republicanism maybe the 1830 revolution
had gone to his head maybe he worried
how his anti-monarchy father would feel
knowing his son was cozy with the king
whatever the truth one thing was certain
rich patron or no rich patron dumar
would be there
when the next uprising came he didn't
have to wait very long
in 1832 a cholera epidemic hit paris
carrying away some 20 000 souls
among them was a famous republican
politician his funeral on june 5th
turned into a show of strength for
opponents of the july monarchy
thousands marched through paris
brandishing guns and this being paris
you can
probably guess what happened next the
1832 revolution is best known today for
being the subject of
le miserables and thus inflicting on
future generations the
sound of russell crowe's singing do not
forget my name
in 1832 though it was mostly known for
the way the july monarchy hit back
like a ufc fighter nearly a hundred were
killed as louis philippe's men retook
the streets
among the dead was alexander dumar
at least that's what the newspapers
reported in reality dumar escaped the
fighting without a scratch
but that didn't mean something more than
a scratch might not be coming
you know the kind of scratch that begins
with a falling blade and ends with your
head
in a basket so demar skipped town
hightailing it to switzerland until the
heat was off he almost neededn't
bothered
louis philippe was almost comically
forgiving towards his favorites and
dumar was allowed back into paris by
so why bother even mentioning this
episode well while in switzerland dumas
started keeping notes of his travels
when he read them back he
discovered his prose was far livelier
than his playwriting had ever been it
was the beginning of a process that
would see him slowly move away
from theater and toward writing novels
but the key word here
is slowly dumar was a guy with expensive
habits from how he dressed to what he
ate to where he lived
his talent might have suited novel
writing but the bailiffs knocking at his
door
suggested he stick with putting on
lucrative plays
luckily for future readers though 1830s
france was about to undergo yet another
revolution
only this revolution wouldn't take place
in the streets but in print rooms
and newspaper offices and it wouldn't
involve bullets and barricades
but serialized stories in the middle of
the decade the dawn of print advertising
allowed newspaper publishers to
put out cheaper titles aimed not at the
wealthy but the lower middle classes
to make sure their new readers kept
coming back editors hit on the idea of
including stories that
ended on cliffhangers tales that would
leave readers desperate
to buy the next edition suddenly writing
for papers was the premiere way to make
cash head of playwriting ahead of
standard novel writing it wouldn't be
long before dumar decided to leap onto
the new bandwagon
in doing so he would create some of
literature's enduring masterpieces
[Music]
if your image of a novelist is a lone
figure typing away in solitude well
prepare for disappointment from the
moment he first turned to prose dumar
didn't so much
write his novels as oversee a production
line that did the writing for him the
practice began in 1838 when dumas saw
the new trend for serialized stories and
decided to turn one of his plays
into a book rather than sweat it out
himself he decided to hire a bunch of
anonymous scribes then oversaw the
editing and rewrites
to our modern ears that sounds kind of
screwy like demar was taking credit for
someone else's labor but at the time
it was a not uncommon practice 19th
century readers didn't expect their
authors to have wrestled with every damn
sentence in the book their name on the
cover was just meant to be a sign of
quality control
and dumas was a master at taking the
skeleton outlines that his assistants
produced and turning them into
living high quality stories but it would
be his collaboration with just one of
these assistants that produced his
greatest work
auguste mackay was a former history
professor now trying to write adventure
stories without much success
but one day he gave dumar his manuscript
to look over finding an exciting plot
buried under laden prose
dumar rewrote the whole thing making it
snappier lighter
more fun he then sold the reworded
version under his own name and
gave mckay 1200 francs in compensation
from these
humble beginnings sprang one of
literature's greatest collaborations
the tall neat mackay became the perfect
assistant for
the increasingly retuned and lively
dumas the former professor would sift
through history books looking for
stories that might make good fiction
then produce outlines
dumar would then take these outlines and
rework them to be more exciting more
compelling the
character's more life like they were the
lennon mccartney of
adventure fiction like just see how many
of their titles you recognize
the three musketeers the counter monte
cristo the man in the iron mask
the valois romances these are books that
are still world famous today
thrilling works of escapism that mixed
history with romance and adventure
dumar himself must have realized the
pair were onto something although
their collaborations all went out onto
the solo credit alexander du mar
they still worked together on 18
separate novels today it's fashionable
for some to say
that mckay was the real talent but given
how much of dumas own experiences
including his dad's war stories or in
the novels
that does seem unlikely whatever the
real drive the partnership made the pair
rich and dumas famous people that simply
never read anything
this damn good before never felt
themselves swept away into a fictional
world that
seemed so real it was the recognition
that dumar had dreamed of
since he first arrived in paris by the
late 1840s he was building his own
theater
and had bought a vast mansion dubbed
montecristo
when his old patron king louis philippe
was deposed in yet another revolution in
1848 because
well this is france dumar even decided
to run for government but while the
years
to 1848 were undoubtedly good times they
would come to an
end all too soon although it would live
for another two decades dumas could have
no way of knowing that by 1848 his time
at the top
was already almost over
all his life dumar had harbored a
not-so-secret urge to do
something serious to become a republican
hero like his old dad
in 1848 that meant campaigning to be
elected to the new
national assembly it was at this point
sadly that dumar ran
smack into the bedsheet-wearing wall of
racism
although only a quarter black dumas had
spent his entire literary career dealing
with cartoonists depicting him as
ape-like and
journalists writing ethnic slurs about
him one representative example goes
scratch m dumas hide and you will find
the savage
a negro but it was only in the
revolutionary year of 1848 that his
mixed heritage really began holding him
back
when dumar tried to find a district
meeting that would support his candidacy
he found himself often drowned out with
chance of
oh ho the negro it must have been a
supremely
bitter experience but even if he had
managed to stand for election
it's doubtless he could have stopped
what was coming next
that december an absurd clown of a man
was elected france's first president
on a populist ticket known as louis
napoleon he was the nephew of napoleon
bonaparte
and his election would mark the slow
death of all republican dreams
and the return of france to an empire
for dumar
this was the beginning of the end the
year after louis napoleon took power
the author left for self-imposed exile
in brussels in this strange new era the
public no longer had an appetite for his
escapist fiction his
theater had gone bust his villa
repossessed it didn't help that he'd
also fallen out with mckay who'd
eventually sue for equal credit on all
18 of their novels while the courts
would find demar could keep his sole
author credit they ordered him to pay
mckay
25 of all royalties yet received it was
an order that left him
not just broke but drowning in debt he
never really recovered from that
across the 1850s dumar tried to muscle
into politics publishing journals
promoting his views but with louis
napoleon now emperor napoleon iii
there was simply no room in paris for a
has-been republican
with mckay gone and exiled from his
readership dumar could do nothing but
watch as his stories fell out of fashion
as
tastes changed his one consolation may
be that his son was becoming wildly
popular in this new era just as dumar
himself had
once become a star in the days of the
july monarchy not that dumas was content
to go gentle into the good night
determined to be a revolutionary he
headed south where he fought for
garibaldi during the italian campaigns
of unification
but dimar was no general alex by 1860 he
was back in france exhausted
dissolute and no longer able to
effectively write although he had a
minor renaissance as a food critic it
wasn't enough to save him from either
obscurity
or poverty alizon dumas spent the last
years of his life living off his son who
obligingly paid his father's bills in
1870 the pair even moved in together the
closest they'd been in de mar fee's
adult life
that winter dumar suddenly asked his son
if he thought his work would last
wendy my junior assured him people would
still be reading it over a hundred years
later
the old man is said to have given him a
contented smile alexander dimar died the
very next day december 5th
1870 at the age of 68. he lived just
long enough to see
one final revolution bring down napoleon
iii
from this point on barring a brief
period in world war ii
france would always be the republic he'd
dreamed of
decades on from his death we can see
that dumafi was right
here we are over 150 years later and all
of us still recognize the words
all for one and one for all when you
consider the countless authors who've
been forgotten
that's no mean feat and it speaks to how
universal dumas books were
how they spoke to a little something
inside all of us that tiny part of our
souls that
crave adventure and to escape into
romantic
swashbuckling past today even the
establishment has finally embraced yuma
in 2002 his remains were
reinterred in the pantheon in a stirring
speech at the ceremony french president
jacques shirak pointedly apologized to
the racism the author had suffered in
his lifetime
yet even if france had never officially
recognized its most popular writer dumas
would still be deserving of this video
the last century and a half his words
have electrified generations of readers
his characters phrases and ideas are
part of our cultural fabric
part of how we see and interact with the
world around us
he may have been brought up in dire
poverty but in the end
the life of alexander dumar bestowed
untold riches
on readers everywhere
so i really hope you enjoyed this video
if you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below don't forget to subscribe
as always thank you for watching